oh thanks everyone happy Friday
my name ishan I'm trying to keep
everyone
engaged right before lunch so hopefully
it's an exciting thing for you
so a little bit about me always not like
I'm bragging about I'm leading on
machine learning and all those passwords
or or I'm a PhD you know what does that
mean but what interesting about me is I
I joined the top leading agriculture
company as my first job
roughly 10 years ago as one of the
machine learning deep learning
scientists and people really didn't
understand what I mean and I still
remember those days where it took me
like a full day to just configure my
local Dev environment I have to
configure the Seattle back end and
they're all kind of dependency conflicts
and that you could address one thing of
them and just keep the way it was like
don't touch it don't touch my computer
and if if another developer asked me to
set up his I'm like I need to you know
consider really really long time try to
should I want to spend another eight
hours just on this again so it's a it's
a very interesting Journey it's also
kind of reflect how easy life is for
data scientists we I sort of feel like
I'm spoiled I just pull the container
and just run run your Docker just
everywhere you want to be it will
reproduce exactly what you want to do so
life is much easier right now
so I'm leading machine learning strategy
at object Computing and in a
in today's talk I want to kind of show
you some of the real world challenges as
we're kind of servicing our clients
across different Industries and how we
are going to tackle that leveraging part
of the machine learning life cycle and
some of the other kind of bespoke
solutions that we're providing and I'm
going to walk through some case studies
and for those of you who are very
familiar with this machine learning
space don't laugh at me just you know
take a step back and try to pound what I
want to the point I'm trying to make and
then I'm going to talk about our kind of
Solutions in terms of the the the
products we're building here to make our
clients life easier make everybody's
life easier
um so um start with these industries
um maybe some of the other consultant
companies are also facing the challenges
that every industry has their own
problem there's different business
segments where we're seeing here take
the agriculture uh because I I knew that
very very well and I see some of the old
colleagues uh Hey Vijay English and he's
going to mention that as in agriculture
people are really caring about a product
selection so seed product why my field
at the Missouri is very different from
your field as in Nebraska because
Nebraska always do irrigation Missouri
does not do that so how would that make
my seat selection a little bit different
we call that Taylor solution and that
really poses very uh you know uh
challenging problem like how we should
characterize your farm versus mine so
that's the very very one of the problem
in agriculture people are trying to
tackle and in healthcare there's many
many problems in healthcare and one of
them is deals with computer vision in
computer vision in healthcare
industry you you look at x-ray you look
at MRI but in agriculture for the same
computer vision problem you're probably
looking at satellite imagery you're
looking at drone you're looking at some
of the cell phone images so they're both
kind of in the
broader categories of computer vision
space but they have they're dealing with
totally different data how the data are
collected and very very different so how
are we going to find the experts in
different agriculture in different
Industries and try to develop this box
solutions that just to solve the problem
while one solution is you can just keep
hiring you're hiring the people that
knows exactly what needs to happen in
each industry and however this it's hard
relief to find I I know a lot of
companies today are really hiring for
people and for for us it's extremely
hard to fire hire those not it's not
hard to fire it's also hard to fire but
it's it's also it's extremely hard to
hire people who know a little bit of
everything and we call those people
unicorn people I would be very happy if
if this this person comes with one or
two Blended disciplines I'll be very
happy to just uh to make give this
person an offer
um so um I want to talk about machine
learning life cycle I think the previous
speaker also talked about that uh
briefly but I want to anchor on this
because that's kind of the uh the basic
principle we are sticking with as uh as
this uh this our machine learning team
is leading to this maturity level
so for those of you who are not familiar
with machine learning life cycle this is
one of the critical takeaways I want
everybody to to remember there's another
another critical one I'll mention that
later
um but there are basically three stages
when we perform machine learning
projects across organizations across
Industries it involves with data
involves this model involves the
deployment so when you talk about data
you're talking about different how are
we going to discover discuss uh discover
different data sources or the data
sources on-prem or they're on cloud or
do I need to do something different in
order to bring the data to the right
shape so some some of the things you
might familiar with like feature
engineering which I think is really the
key and critical step in this overall
success of machine learning performance
and those labeling like human annotation
we just assume the data are cleaned
that's how data scientists often think
but that's another case takes efforts to
label those data to clean up those data
and put them in a shape that are
convenient for data scientists to build
model upon the modeling side is uh
relatively compared to the data set is
actually the fun part because you got to
try those cool models like computer
vision in the convolutional neural
network in the ostm in the language
space and some other time series and you
know generative model again model those
are the coolest area data scientists
want to spend their time on another
deployment side there's a lot of ml
upside
how we make sure the model drifts is
handled there's not much bias and
uh weird things happen after your model
deployed so so a bunch of interesting
cycle processes are happening in this in
the cycle uh in the in the next real
real world case study I want to focus on
the data and model part and I'll just
put the deployment side
um just just within the scope of the of
this talk
so we take the machine learning life
cycle
to the next level because you know you
can talk about this three different
stages but how right how how we how are
you going to map those basic principles
to these different Industries so one
approach we're taking at object
Computing is we actually see there are
similar gists across these different
Industries
as much as the connections are
illustrative I want to give you an idea
of different Industries they share
different pipelines or solution
buckets and we identify those and we
have way complicated mapping than this
but just this is to give you a flavor of
how would this different
solution categories can map to different
Industries once you've done that kind of
exercise your life is actually much
easier because you can reuse that
Solutions on new industries that you
probably
um have a little you know Comfort level
however once you understand the the the
you know the the domains me side of
things uh reuse the solution you build
for the previous uh industry or previous
Solutions is going to match either
so to further illustrate that I want to
go through a very toy it's a toy example
it's a case study and you know I cannot
go wrong with with paths right it's
actually a real word uh problem we
worked with a pet food company where
they're trying to accelerate their
adoption and food selection process so
automated computer vision and
classification tasks about pet breed so
in this case I want to simplify that so
we're having a bunch of pictures I have
a dog and cats and in in machine
learning we use
a particular
supervised learning because supervised
learning because it has labels so you
digitize those labels you use one to say
this is a dog and you you want zero to
say this is a cat Okay so that's where
we start
and we assume there's expert who knows
very well about cats and dog and this
guy has very generously put this nice
pictures into two different folders um
regardless is your local drive or in
Cloud doesn't matter but that's one of
the challenge where another challenges
reality you're facing is those images
are going to be of different sizes right
you cannot really control the person
who's taking those images so there are
different field of view and you know
some some people are really bad at
taking pictures so they might not they
might some some of them can be super
blurry and some are are not really
having the object in the middle of the
field of view so that can happen
so what are you going to do you're going
to
do some cropping as you can see on the
second box here uh you you crops image
so we we assume the the the center crop
is the way but you can imagine you can
actually Implement different approach
like random cropping or or some
user-defined cropping based on how well
you know the the person who's taking
those pictures right so uh some
something around there and then you
resize it the reason you resize it is
because uh most convolutional neural
network which is super good as classify
these type of pictures they tend to
require fixed input size so you almost
always have to resize your image
regardless you're using a super super
good iPhone or some other
mediocre
cameras to to take take those pictures
so always resize and then you do the
random sleep random split so for those
of you who are not familiar with the
supervised learning is you always have
to try in it you always have to test it
and you want to make sure your Trend a
test there's no lead leakage that means
you don't you are now cheating you're
not using the pictures that you already
seen in your training data to be to show
up in your testing data because that's
that's like you can memorize things
instead of really learning the the
robust information there
you generally do random split and you
you take 80 percent of the data you
always want to do more for training to
learn more of the the inherent structure
of your data and then you do the testing
which is 20 in let's say in this case so
let's just uh pause for a second and try
to see okay what's the steps I'm taking
here okay because this is basically the
data part as you are correlating with
what I mentioned about the machine
learning life cycle at the at the first
stage but this is the data this
concludes the data part I'm talking
about and then what I'm doing here is
okay I'm going to let the data
scientists to define the mouth or
whatever crazy model or easy model that
was defined through tensorflow pytorch
even psychic learn and then you put into
this trend statement or or fit well
depends on what what framework you're
you're using what this process basically
means okay I tell the model what the
labels what is zero or one is cat or dog
and then I reinforce that connections
through this uh middle part of the
convolution neural network memory so you
heard about neurons and neuron has
memories so that's how this whole
training process works magically behind
the scene so what do I do here I do I do
some cropping I do some resizing I do
some random splits and then I Define my
model and train my model so that's
basically my Approach of dealing with
this classification problem of cat and
dog
let's take another look like this is in
the pet industry right let's look like
this this Transportation industry this
is also a real word uh problem where
servicing our web of our clients they
want to know they want to ID that the
each vehicles in their Fleet they want
to ID those and then linked the
um the goods they're carrying on the app
track or or a car with with identity of
of the car so
so in this problem
it's a very different problem as you can
see because first of all it's cars not
killed um pass anymore and the other
thing is the area you're looking for
which is a license plate is what we call
it identification
is way smaller than the previous case
where your your dog and cats are kind of
taking the majority of the Field view
so so then you might wonder how I'm a
guy going to reuse what I have built
before to tackle this new problem I'm
not going to build everything from
scratch so that's what I'm going to show
you here is
um so once you have that concept and
congratulations I think that's the first
step you want to do is you always pound
on what I'm going what reusability I
have in my portfolio of solutions I can
reuse the first step in this case is we
call it region proposal region proposal
is by itself is a is a research area
there are so many papers talking about
how I can propose the regions I'm
interested in in a Brute Force way you
can do sliding window like you can just
slide different regions and try to go
from there another option like what I'm
doing here is I just random crop
something and with a hope that the plate
is somehow Incorporated entirely in my
region proposal
so once I do that I actually converted
that to one of the problems I'm familiar
with because I can do the same resizing
I can do the same Trend test split and
then
now you know that it's you define a
model you you kind of reinforce again
the the labels and the reinforce the
memories of this convolution neural
network you you might as well just use
the same model definition as you were
using for for cat and dog all it cares
is about the memories or the ways of of
those neurons so if you're lazy as me I
I would just use the same model
architectures and just to throw into
this this training process and when you
if you were to compare with what we did
before on the cat and dog problems the
difference is that you're looking at a
region the actual step of religion
proposal and then you the rest of things
are pretty much the same you are doing a
resizing split Define model and training
model so this is really a toy problem
that is probably so trivial for people
who are running their day-to-day machine
learning tasks
so to make it less actually this is
what's actually behind the scenes we
actually
included this implemented this this full
unified image and object detection
category of support in this in our in
our product one of the products in our
product portfolio is that you can see
this this imagery data we all the I want
to clarify all the yellow boxes are kind
of either user input or
um
it's an entity or store storage kind of
related and the green boxes are the kind
of the apis or some you can consider as
a function or red wrapper that that will
do the job by itself and the the red
arrows are the kind of the what type of
input from that yellow boxes are needed
um going through need to go through
those different apis
so without too much of the intimidation
on this fairly complicated diagram what
you can actually see some familiarities
to what I talked about before right you
you are doing some pre-processing in
this pre-processing we are incorporating
more of the the capacities way richer
than what I showed before about resizing
and cropping that kind of thing you
actually do a lot of image augmentation
which is very common in computer video
space
uh so I'll just start from there like
the imagery data I you you need to I
don't really care about where it comes
from we have handlers to handle where
the data are stored on-prem or on AWS S3
or on gcp GCS I don't I don't really
care we can handle that
um the the major part in this whole
process to me is really the
configuration API we're really hoping to
have the user to only click one button
and have a centralized place to input
their requirements then really clicking
through different buttons like you're
doing in your jupyter notebook is
it's for practitioners that's fine but
for some of our business users it can be
a little bit cumbersome when you think
about
um okay I have to do more than I need to
do
um so so that's kind of the centralized
place where you can Define your your
task type it's either imagery
classification or it's an object
detection problem
or do you want to
specify some of the other hyper
parameters you want to choose or just
let
the product to kind of choose by itself
and one outstanding thing I want to
mention is as much as we want the user
to have the flexibility to input their
own configuration we also have a lot of
default setting just to make this as
easy as as it can be because we know
some some customers like like yeah we
trust you can select the best you can I
I don't really have a preference so we
want to suit that needs as well so if if
the user does not define well just
recommend the best parameter settings so
that the user will get really one button
away from what they were looking for
and then this typical model training API
in Commerce is different small apis on
the on the training and evaluation and
then the model artifact is is saved to
the design location which is also
defined by by this configuration API
so I'll
this is basically our Solutions and we
actually have different uh
portfolio items I call this one of the
portfolio but I was giving a talk on the
other week where the one of the audience
members asking how about the other task
in contribution space for example the
segmentation unfortunately for
segmentation we have it in a separate
product portfolio that does not fit in
the space just because in segmentation
space you are looking for pixel level
that kind of granularity that it's
really hard to to fit in this overall
workflow so that's something you really
need to think about when you want to
design a system like this how are going
to assess the level of generalization or
reusability so that you have the right
balance of yes this problem this this
system is just so generic that I have to
do a lot of
tedious manipulation versus
I I want to uh I just wanted this to
solve a particular problem then it
becomes a overwhelming of a product
portfolio
so that's uh learning so you know try
not to make make this uh other of a
sales page because I'm I'm a data
scientist by training I do want to
highlight that uh this life cycle is the
integrative process and it requires
expertise across disciplines and I want
to iterate more that this is hard to
find a unicorn where you you kind of
know
all the toolings and the handshake
process through data model and deploy
that's what we feel like in order to
really improve the team productivity a
good approach will be you make those
portfolio items through across this as
easy to use even we are opening our
product to our internal development team
so they without just too much of diving
deep into hey what exactly the mod the
model wants
um this this data engineer can just
go through there themselves and explore
that conveniently and we're really
seeing the the the efficiency in
delivering and to end the solution
through through this approach so that's
kind of a realistic resource of how we
are really augmenting the the team's
deliverables Without Really hiring uh so
many unicorn persons
so I think I want to
add a little you know contact thing and
feel free to to chat chat with me on on
this uh different connecting approaches
and with that that will conclude my
presentation I want to open up for any
questions as I want to
I'm sure there's uh experts in this in
this room are
wondering about the different things so
thanks everyone
[Applause]
I want to get your question Christ your
question about how
what's the best strategy to test the
model as is part of the offering of the
integrated Software System
yeah I think that's a that's a really a
pen we were experiencing as well as
machine learning try to mingle with the
traditional software space it's
definitely a lot of I I often see people
like the same project team and they were
talking and they don't really know what
each other is talking about and there
are so many terminologies in this
modeling space are very unique to to
this space then it becomes a disaster
with with a lack of productivity so this
is exactly what we're trying to address
here with this relatively integrated
framework is you you you try to
standardize the model input and output I
don't know if that makes sense because I
don't really care I mean for for
deployment side or software style you
don't really care about is this
tensorflow model or Pi torch model or
secular model there should be a standard
format
when they when the handoff or the M your
ml Engineers are are thinking about
right so so how think about what the
type of model output is that uh going to
be a uh
a continuous output or it's going to be
a discrete output it will be numbers or
or how how would that look like so try
to think challenge yourself on
um is there a common standards you're
trying to uh
categorize those different output that
you can work with your your ml opt-in to
agree on that kind of format so that's
something we find very very useful and
the other thing on the um on the data
side I will show that really on the
Upstream side is we
we really mingle the data engineer and
and the data scientists together in
various
projects and settings where when when
data Engineers are kind of building
their data models we will make sure the
data scientists also in the room so they
are like the stakeholders into some some
extent that they they need to have a
voice on how you design your entity
mapping and how how you define your your
nodes in a graph context how to design
your nodes how what kind of relationship
I I want this this data entities to to
with each other so so that's another
thing where keep pushing towards that
end yeah
uh all you so your question is about
automated strategy testing of the models
so uh a good good question so when we we
are doing you know on uh
beside the regular uh unit test where
you're kind of try to make sure you're
you're doing the thing you want to do
for each of the things you you we we
normally use Pi test to kind of deal
with those uh those small blocks of of
modulars data scientists are developing
um that's kind of the I I I like it I
think it's it has a very convenient
plugin and not too scary for for data
scientists so yeah
yeah so so besides this this pie test we
we also want to you know sometimes
testing can be an Admire for developers
because sometimes we feel like we we
actually wrote more testing scripts than
the actual the the the the software
itself right so that's good because we
are you're trying to have enough
coverage of what your function can
handle so you can you're really
iterating your your features uh in in
your what you are trying to offer but
there's uh
this cut to me I feel like it's actually
involved with uh how much of a business
need you want
to to cover the type of modules you you
want to support that's
actually connects to even Upstream
outside this this the screen that can
fit is the the business side of needs so
that's uh that's another challenge you
then you can factor in yeah
yeah so I think in general I'm really
glad that you are asking that question
because that's something even our
clients were not really we had to
educate our clients to to tell them hey
you want to make sure whatever you put
into the production are actually doing
the right thing and there are some
Cadence you you need to factor in so
there's different approach from math or
statistical point of view some
distribution driven
um statistical driven kind of
thresholding or metrics you can you can
kind of embed your typical Cadence of
checking so that's something you
definitely want to do another thing is
we we found successful in one of our
applications is you you actually build
that continuous learning in your model
so there are different models in
particular for forecast models and those
in particular those time series and you
are you should be able to allow the
model to uh
absorb new data as is corrects what it
has predicted in the past so the model
architecture itself is actually allowing
that continuous learning just by by
choosing the right architect and the
architecture and algorithm I don't know
if that makes sense but we can chat more
this is a very interesting area and we
we would hope we will be doing more
interesting and Innovations
yeah so that's a good question I was at
the Google
data and AI so I'm going to borrow some
of that because I agree with what Google
said two weeks ago for the most part
um the one not one of the trend is uh
code free so it's really try to open up
a playground for uh for business
stakeholders to you know get their hands
dirty but not really too deep into the
width but they're able to
prescribe their business requirements
through some of the automated process so
that's actually in line with what we're
doing here as well as as you're thinking
about we take care of 90 of the work and
the user just you need to input their
requirements and one button away they're
they're getting what they want for
example in in some of the the software's
both AWS and gcp provides they actually
a lot of SQL query behind the scene and
also some of the
tabular
software I think is still in r d I'm
sure but another R director and they
were actually saying Okay
um please give me the what's the trend
for the housing price in San Francisco
in next 10 years you just do that in NLP
so that you can imagine a lot of NLP
going going on at the background and you
are seeing a pretty dashboard that
what's happening behind the scenes is
pulling based on the sentiment analysis
of what I say
it does the query of the data and SQL
whatever and building some analysis
behind the scene it does that all by its
own and you don't really all you need to
do is to say what you want so I think
that's pretty cool I'm not sure if
that's integrated to the tabular uh
product offering yet but that's
definitely one of the trend is no code
or less code another part in terms of
the trend
um which which I think is very
interesting is to more emphasizing on
the human in the loop so human Loop
for those of you who are familiar with
this annotation is you you actually
allow the user to interfere with how
machine learning is working so the the
human Loop becomes a very popular
concept of ever since and now in the
English business setting sometimes the
domain knowledge can be true of a
nebulous to capture in typical machine
learning setting so what you want to do
is you allow
this me to interfere the process
whenever the person sees some abnormal
things and he or she can actually
interfere and override what the machine
learning all the critics or is trying to
do so and everything is fully
transparent in that space so I think
that's a really cool thing I'm also
going to explore in our product
development career as well
cool I think
about the time so thanks to everyone's
attention and have a have a good lunch
and have a good weekend have fun